logan as one of the
attorneys in this movie what is
something that you learned from filming
these super complicated puzzle scenes in
film one that you found coming in handy
this time around
i learned nothing really it just uh
continued to be as torturous as the
first one but um
you know the thing is uh the character
has changed
um where he was a cynical
cigarette smoking um just
kind of a-hole in the first one he
becomes this um
guy that finds a second chance at life
and he wants to come
um at this with full force he wants to
support
zoe in the journey to take down minos
and so he really has uh more of a heroic
element
um within the second one and um yeah we
um
were able to come together and uh it
he learns a lot more about teamwork in
the sense of all of this
i remember hearing that the billiard
room in film one took the most amount of
time
to shoot so what earned that honor on
this film what what shoot lasted the
longest for all the game rooms
either the subway or or the show it was
the subway
was the first one and i think that um we
really wanted to
hit the ground running with the first
room really make uh
that pop for the audience and um wow i
mean what i
saw in the trailer and i saw in the film
was
something that i didn't ever expect
it was a an added element that um just
felt super real
and i was just amazed at what they were
able to accomplish
i was going to guess the bank that was
hard too
all of them were hurt for myself just
because the counters were high and i had
to do the most amount of jumping
onto the counters and you weren't
allowed to use your hands because
that might set something off and so it
was just
near impossible jumping to something
that's here with your feet and somehow
have a forefoot
that's a different movie that's a marvel
movie so um
so yeah that was my hardest stunt
holland just because
i'm a little obsessed with channel zero
and i think that this world is a better
place if we keep talking about it
is there anything that you picked up
working on butcher's block that you find
coming in handy and new projects
uh that you do in the horror genre yeah
i
am about to actually go play a role
where i am multiple characters
um and so uh schizophrenia is almost
it's almost like a term of cancer
there's an umbrella of different kinds
of schizophrenic people and so
um this is a different kind of
schizophrenic person but
through channel zero i actually found a
lot of inspiration
of diving into different books and
youtube channels um
dealing with different types of
schizophrenia yeah
we need more of these movies and we need
more installments of channel zero i'm
very brokenhearted that that came to an
end
yeah nick nick was lovely to work with
and olivia's a friend of of uh both
logan and i so the world's collide
i like hearing that good good people
good talent colliding is always good for
all of us on the other end of things
um logan is this the first time you've
been in a movie sequel where you get to
reprise a role
uh yeah i believe so um
you know it was great being able to
continue the story i mean i've done some
series roles where it's like you know
you continue to
live the story um but that's a kind of a
day in day out situation
but um yeah i mean two years later here
we are working um
with uh ben and zoe and trying to figure
out like how we can
take down this evil first known as minos
and so
you know it gave us the time to kind of
really ponder on
how we were going to continue this
series and that was a big collaborative
experience with adam myself
taylor and the rest of the creative crew
and
so um the great thing is is everybody
listens and everybody has kind of a say
in what goes and
i got to sit down with adam and the
screenwriter to try to figure out
how i would portray this character the
best and you know
my voice was heard and it was it was
great to be able to collaborate in that
experience again
that's super cool to hear especially
when in in the tv realm i imagine you're
working with a different director every
single episode so it's probably nice to
build that rapport
absolutely yes so this is a little uh
random but it kind of feels akin to
escape rooms
if both of you had the opportunity to be
a contestant
on the game show of your choice what
would you pick and why oh
damn well you know i want to be
on wipeout because you know i've
experienced all of this torture in the
movie
so if there's a couple of pads and some
dirty water
hell i could win i believe
that would be really fun as a rachel
reverse i'll i'll take you up on that
logan
um i also think it's not really a game
show but
um i am an amazing race freak
and would give anything to be on a show
they those both feel like they kind of
align with escape room to a degree
absolutely we are one of the global
torture ones you know
a day in the park torture yeah maybe
maybe that will
you know make this uh a fine trilogy
we'll do escape room
meets amazing race meets wipeout let's
do it i could see it happening
where where do you guys stand on extreme
haunted houses
would you ever do something like that or
do you have limits
i almost appreciate the haunted house
experience a bit more than the escape
room experience myself because
um there's always room to run away
um in the escape room you're always kind
of stuck until you can figure things out
um i yeah i've grown a
thick callus on what is scary to me
throughout the years of working on you
know horrorific things
and so um yeah i'd say bring it on
give me that ten room ten leveled uh
haunted house or whatever and i'll be
able to experience
at go look up black blackout haunted
houses after this and i think you might
rethink the answer to that question
i i was supposed to go on a haunted
house tour
nationwide it was a bucket listing of
mine and
uh channel zero actually made me so that
i couldn't go
uh schedule wise but i still on my list
there's one in wisconsin i believe
that is a cornfield and uh you have a
paintball gun and so do the zombies so
it's like this paintball meets
uh you know haunted house theme um
so that was like one i'm looking forward
to and now i'm gonna be checking out
blackout
um i don't know if i should have
recommended that to you but
if you do it let me know what you think
about it before they kick me out of here
logan i have one spoiler question for
you don't worry we will save this for
after the movie's released
in the moment as you're playing it on
that plane
what's going through ben's mind or or
rather what do you think his next move
is going to be
is he going to put on the oxygen mask
like everyone around him or does he look
at zoe and know that
something's up minos has them again
first he says oh no not again
and then um second uh
yeah i mean listen i think that they've
been
tortured enough they it they've grown
accustomed to this
and so now um they need to
you know take the reins and just do
whatever they can
not going to put that oxygen mask on
because who knows what's going in there
i mean
although gas is getting thrown into the
experience too so
god you know i i wish i thought that far
but then they yelled cut and i was tired
so it's time
to um to think on it until the next one
that's totally fair as long as i get an
another one so
thank you guys for your time today big
congrats on this one and
see you next time